When you implement a method, you can make use of a special variable called this
that references this very object on which a method is called. Here's what I
mean. Look at this method call. It has an argument, number ten, and that
argument gets copied into this parameter variable. So now distance is ten, and
whenever you use distance, that means ten. Now, when you look at this car, it
really has two ingredients, the number ten but also the particular car. And
every method in Java has a secret parameter called this that's not actually
declare in the method but, in any call, it references the object to the left of
the dot. Now, what's the use? If you like, you can add this in front of every
instance variable. Let's clean it up a little. So, now it becomes very clear
that it's the miles driven of this car that are set to the miles driven of this
car plus the distance. And the distance was a parameter variable. It's optional
to use this but some people like it a lot because it makes it very clear, which
are the instance variables and which ones are local or parameter variables. A
bit of terminology by the way, this is sometimes called the implicit parameter
because it's never declared. It's implicit in the definition of a method. And a
parameter such as this one here is called an explicit parameter. Why don't you
give it a try? Here in this drive method, go ahead and add this everywhere that
your allowed to do so. How many times did you get to add this and did you like
it better this way? No wrong answer, I'd just like to know.